the UK didn't vote on austerity policies  he didn't vote on the insufficient  protection of external borders the UK is  not a member state of the euro so the  Euro policies don't apply to the UK the  UK isn't part of the Schengen area so  the United Kingdom is master of its own  border so let's not invent anything  because Mr Farage that is telling us  stories you told us a few days ago that  you made a mistake on the budgetary  aspects of what was at stake in the  relationship between the EU and the UK  if you said that if you'd said that  before the vote then I wouldn't need to  congratulate you but you lied you didn't  tell the truth you fabricated reality  yeah I'm enjoy baiting with you sparring  with you Mr Farage I think we share a  similar sense of humor  you used to have a sense of humor I  still do I think but I find it  regrettable that this is going to be the  last occasion that we'll be able to  debate because you won't be coming back